foreign
it is the sharing of this moment that
makes it so poignant
a national coming together where the
collective purpose never falters
this ritual was observed in all corners
of the UK
it was the first Armistice Day since the
passing of Queen Elizabeth II at the
National Memorial Arboretum in
staffordshire they remembered her
service
the country loaded its whole self into
your slender hands
hands that can rest now relieved of a
Century's weight
for many here it was about their own
Fallen comrades you don't want to forget
them you don't want to forget what you
did I mean I had 23 years in the Army
and I had lots and lots of good times
and because you always remember the good
times you don't remember the bad times
so much
but those times where you lose people
you everybody goes quiet for a while
of course this time of remembrance comes
as war is again being waged in Europe
The Trenches on the front lines in
Ukraine look like they belong to
previous generations but Russian and
Ukrainian lives are being lost today
in Canterbury which is now home for
Yulia she paused to reflect it's so
important to understand that peace is
something that has to be cherished is
something that we have to look after
otherwise it's just so easily lost
every episode of warfare carries an
enormous burden as well as memories that
endure
Lisa Dowd Sky News Staffordshire